we've been recently getting some very  disappointing leaks and rumors  concerning this new iphone se3 and if  they turn out to be true this will be  the worst iphone upgrade in apple's  history earlier this month dylan dkt  finally came back and updated his tweet  saying that we'll be simply getting the  same iphone se designed from 2020 except  now with 5g and a spec bump if you look  at any of the android competition  they're giving us modern smartphones for  around the same price if apple is using  the same exact design and chassis for  the new iphone se3 and adding 5g and a  spec bump the battery life will likely  be even worse so paying 50 dollars more  for the pixel 5a with 5g to get a  battery that's two and a half times  bigger is definitely worth it along with  all of the other advantages i just don't  think that it's enough for apple to add  5g and upgraded specs of the iphone sc  because those things aren't enough to  make it compelling